lors d'une fin la fin d'une soirée entre
amis vous savez des soirées que l'on
passe avec les la famille ou les amis et
on se retrouve en fin de compte à parler
de politique de problèmes de société
alors pas les salaires booth pas lé prix
augmentent y a pas d'eau robinet à la
rentrée ya pas eu d' instits ou de profs
dans les lycées les politiques ceux ci
les politiques cela et ainsi de suite et
c'est pesant et c'est négatif est pas
moi en rentrant je me suis dit non ça
suffit basta faut qu'on fasse quelque
chose et qu'on fasse quelque chose de
positif pour que ça aille mieux
ce que le constat on l'a tous fait ça va
mal mais qui sait qui est âgée il est
vrai que dans le même temps j'avais
découvert en fin de compte le mouvement
de pierre rabhi les colibris un
mouvement humaniste écologiste qui prône
le changement par la consommation qui
met en avant des solutions qui peuvent
nous aider nous citoyens aller mieux
dans ce monde qui va mal alors en
fouillant sur le net j'ai découvert la
gratifient ria je pense que certains
mais pas mal d'entre vous doivent
connaître maintenant la gratifier ria
cet argentin c'est né en argentine grâce
à un jeune étudiant argentin ariel bosio
qui à force de déménager pendant ses
études a préféré déposer ses affaires
superflu unis tulle aux barques de seul
immeuble de son immeuble afin que
d'autres viennent les chercher les
prendre gratuitement et ça tellement
plus convaincant qu'ils ont envahi les
places d'argentine et ce mouvement qui
prône la gratuité
eh bien il envahit le monde en ce moment
il y en a en france métropolitaine il y
en a en belgique qui en en espagne en
italie en angleterre il y en a en grèce
il y en a la chaire en amérique latine y
en a en amérique du nord et on en a une
ici aussi
alors pour vous faire comprendre ce que
c'est que la gratifier ria on a
l'habitude de dire que à la gratte y
feria on vient avec ou sans rien et on
repart avec ce dont on a besoin sans
réciprocité et sans argent
alors imaginez une grande brocante une
brocante normal un marché aux puces
balaïa pas d'argent mais rien pas
d'argent on vient avec don vient de
donner avec le choeur des objets dans
n'a plus l'utilité
et là on retrouve un bonheur un sourire
de la joie de l' envie de bouger envie
de faire évoluer le monde et comme il
n'y a pas de réciprocité il n'y a pas
d'argent
eh ben on redonne de la valeur à l'homme
et pas à l'objet concrètement chez vous
imaginez tous chez vous vos placards la
cuisine une armada de petites cuillères
des assiettes à revendre des canaris qui
traîne de l'électroménager qu'on a
acheté parce que parce que c'était la
mode et dont se sert jamais le placard
de madame personne n'a dans son placard
une petite robe qu'on garde les on va ça
mettra et puis on la met jamais les
enfants leur chambre joue toujours avec
les mêmes objets les mêmes jouer les
autres et dorment dans les placards
sagement monsieur n'est pas en reste
entre ces jeux vidéo ces lectures enfin
ces axes occupation on a tous un placard
rempli de vieux câbles un tiroir plein
de vieux câbles de télécommande ou
refaire nom et vos voisins
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont chez eux les
voisins pas la même chose alors pourquoi
est-ce qu'on devrait entassés pourquoi
est-ce qu'on devrait vendre pourquoi
est-ce qu'on devrait jeter ces objets
dont on se sert plus alors que d'autres
en ont besoin et attention quand j'ai
d'autres c'est tout le monde c'est pas
une catégorie sociale ou une catégorie
raciale ainsi de suite
tout le monde l'a gratifié à la 3 buts
mais avant de vous donner ces trois buts
je vais vous
dire quelque chose et la vidéo qu'on
vient de voir elle va vous l'expliquer
dont la gratifie d'un dans la société
actuellement depuis des siècles mais
vraiment depuis des siècles on nous met
dans des cases
on est noir on est blanc on est riche on
est pauvre on est de droite
on est de gauche on est musulman on est
catholique ont noué dans des cases et on
se divise comme ça et comme on est
divisés mais qu'est ce qui se passe on
se déteste on sait la guerre et bella
gratuit férial dit non ça suffit on est
juste habitants de la planète qu'on
vient de voir l a pas besoin de nous
mais pour l'instant on l'a fait mourir
et c'est à nous citoyens de faire en
sorte qu'elle aille mieux parce qu'il a
pas de planète de rechange si on
continue comme ça on ira droit dans le
mur
elle elle ira bien mais nous on sera
plus là et donc par là gratis arias on a
décidé d'agir d'agir avec le sourire
positivement de mettre en avant des
solutions positives et guay ce n'est pas
toujours le marasme économique on peut
faire des choses nous citoyens pour que
ça bouge alors les trois buts de la
gratifier rial dont je vous parlais
c'est le premier le sait ne plus polluer
ensuite sortir la société de
consommation et ensuite recréer du lien
entre humains imaginez vous venez donner
à la gratifier ya des objets dont vous
ne vous servez plus vous ne polluez plus
puisque vous ne souhaitez pas et si vous
acceptez de prendre dans les mains
d'autres personnes des objets dont vous
aurez l'utilité vous sortez de la
société de consommation mais surtout
qu'est-ce qui se passe comme vous parlez
entre vous on parle entre nous on se
rencontre on recrée du lien entre
humains et ça c'est super important
le lien entre humains l'a gratifié ria
est né en guadeloupe il y a trois ans le
16 novembre 2013 et à la première gritti
feria nous étions 20 notre mon cercle
d'amis plus une personne qui avait
croisé l'événement sur facebook et qui
s'étaient joints nous ferait toujours un
peu de tendresse pour cette personne là
et à la deuxième on s'est retrouvé sans
on n'a pas compris on se demandait mais
comment ça se fait c'était juste qu'en
fait le bouche à oreille les valeurs de
bon sens on parlait et les gens sont
venus et de fil en aiguille de moins en
moins parce que la créati feriel se
tient tous les mois eh ben on à
rencontrer de nouvelles personnes et ces
nouvelles personnes ont fait grossir les
équipes qui organise et du coup
maintenant elle n'est plus qu'à saint
françois la gratifient rien parce qu'au
début elle était à saint françois
elle se fait aussi sur vieux habitants
elle a commencé sur pointe noire on a
fait la toute première le mois dernier
c'était sympa et ça va continuer on a
des projets sur basse-terre aussi votre
sur grande terre
il y aura d'autres créatifs et ria qui
vont se mettre en place en guadeloupe et
il ya une personne de martin et qui m'a
appelé ce qu'elle est sur le groupe
facebook parce que nous avons pêche
un groupe facebook s'appelle gratifia
guadeloupe et on est plus 6000 à peu
près sur le groupe et la personne de
martinique est dans le groupe et de
m'appeler pour savoir comment je peux
faire moi pour faire une gratifié en
marquer tu m'appelles après le tedx on
verra ça
et une dame qui était aussi dans la
gratifiant guadeloupe et qui est rentré
en métropole de capi de paris et qui
m'appelle en bison sophie j'ai mon fils
voilà la brocante il m'a dit maman sma
normal on paye et du coup il me dit pas
est ce que je peux faire aussi gratifié
à paris pas de souci allez on te donner
deux trois petits trucs et toute science
donc on a pris de l'ampleur on a
rencontré des gens ont grossi mais avec
l'auteur toujours avec le coeur toujours
avec l'envié d'avancer d'avancer plus
loin pour qu'on soit tous solidaires
tous des humains sur cette terre pour
qu'on protège et notre environnement et
nos humains les animaux et les plantes
également du coup quand on a cette façon
de voir les choses
elle a gratifié ria c'est du bonheur au
quotidien mais vraiment au quotidien en
fin de compte je vous ai donné dit que
bon il y avait toutes les petites choses
qu'on pouvait ramener à la gratifier
rillieux les vêtements les choses comme
ça mais il ya des gens qui viennent avec
des cageots entiers de fruits qui vont
partager
j'ai vu des portes de placards rentrée
agrati feria ressortir avec un autre
propriétaire
on a vu un monsieur qui avait fini ses
travaux et qui a ramené du ciment colle
et du carrelage
c'est un beau don quand même veut dire
écolo écologiquement et économiquement
on fait des économies vous comprenez on
vend on redonne une seconde vie à des
objets qui auraient été jetés ou vendus
non là c'est gratuit et ça sert il ya un
hôtel qui nous a donné parce qu'il vient
d'être achetée sur sainte anne et nous a
donné ses réseaux et ses housses de
chaises et ben c'est ou de chaises qui
était dans un hôtel vont faire trois
mariages là dans le mois de décembre
c'est magique
il y a un magasin parce qu'en fin de
compte tout le monde s'y met à la gratte
il n'y a pas que les particuliers les
professionnels aussi qui m'envoie un
message
alors on a des congélateurs en panne
qu'est-ce qu'on peut les mettre dans la
gratifient oui on va voir et bien lieu
de trois les trois rangs trouver une
nouvelle vie un sort à réparer de servir
à stocker un deuxième servira de
stockage pour des denrées alimentaires
dans un magasin qui n'avaient pas de
deux d'état l'âge et l'autre va servir à
droite de coffre à jouets une seconde
vie et là en fin de compte je vous ai
parlé que de je vous ai parlé que de ce
qui était matériel dans la gratifier
rien mais là gratifia ce n'est pas que
du matériel
c'est vraiment une façon de vivre c'est
une philosophie de vie et pourquoi on
aime la gratifient rien c'est parce
qu'on est en fin de compte on retrouve
des valeurs de bon sens qu'on a oublié
celle d'anton longtemps sont pas si
vieille que ça en fait surtout ici où on
se parle et où on échange et nos fruits
north est là dans la gratifier ya des
gens qui offrent des cours d'anglais
gratuitement des cours de cuisine il ya
des ateliers qui se font en fait quand
on aime la gratifier ria parce qu on ne
gaspille plus on ne jette plus on
partage on donne on est de bon sens on
coopère on est contre la division et la
compétition on est dans la coopération
et l'amour en tout cas voilà tout ce que
je pouvais vous dire c'est ballack
rétifs à l'est c'est vraiment une belle
façon d'agir parce que nous citoyens
chacun tout ce qu'on est là si on change
nos façons de consommer le monde ira
bien mieux qu on fonce sur nous avant de
compter sur ceux d'en haut
la gratifier riad on pourra trois ans le
20 novembre à saint françois
on va faire une belle fête à une
exposition sur les tortues on a un
atelier aussi qu'il va vous expliquer le
zéro déchet mais à johnson ça vous parle
le verrou déchets on aura aussi des
ateliers pour les enfants
et si vous pouvez pas venir à celle
gratifia là il y en aura une en décembre
et en début d'année y en aura une à
pointe noire
en tout cas voilà ce que j'avais à vous
dire venez nous rejoindre le mouvement
avec le sourire et même chez vous sans
venir à la gratifiant quand vous ouvrez
vos placards cette attention à ce qu'il
ya dedans
et pour finir je vous dirai juste une
phrase de pierre ravis que je vous
demande de méditer l'abondance vient du
partage